sì mangeresti una lumaca o una rana ciao
a tutti
bentornati solite storie sono in italia
io mi parla allora ultimo episodio delle
scelte più difficili al mondo lo scorso
episodio di è piaciuto tantissimo e mi è
piaciuto tantissimo anche a leggere i
vostri commenti e sapere che scelte
avevate fatto ci è piaciuto soprattutto
leggere i commenti in cui spiega morte
perché avevate fatto quelle sceso in
alcune scelte se avete fatto cambiare
idea in altre siamo rimasti scioccati
tipo c'era una scelta butteresti dal
palazzo
l'iphone ten o un gattino e per fortuna
la maggior parte ha risposto ai con ten
però in tanti hanno risposto un cattivo
e alcuni dicevano sì perché i gatti
hanno nove vite quindi se avevano smesso
a 7 e poi altri se come mai gatti che
danno sempre in piedi 6 cavolo ma da
bravo ragazzo si sfracella al si è
invece altre risposte erano scioccanti
tipo non me ne frega niente di un
gattino mio telefono sì ci ha fatto
capire queste cose quel video che ci
sono persone molto diverse nel mondo
comunque questo è il secondo episodio
delle scelte più difficili al mondo come
sempre come dovete partecipare ogni
senza che diremo dovrete scrivere voi la
vostra risposta nei commenti noi daremo
la nostra scelta è fermo il perché
abbiamo dato la nostra scelta siete
pronti mettetevi comodi patatine pop
corre lasciate un bel like se uno se un
terzo episodio e iniziamo subito allora
il numero uno
preferire il professionista premio
strega si trasforma in una rana o in un
topo
e tu cosa preferirebbe se devi per forza
a scegliere l'auto poi un topo si
possono mangiare tutto voglio tutti gli
avanzi di cibo tutte le zozzerie nolan
ammonta solo quelle cose serie incentivi
vinto non leggo che c'è dopo giro va
dove cammina corre schiacciate dalle
persone che non trovano che comunque ti
sento anch'io dopo perché è più oggi che
non lo so mi piace di più i roditori
migrazione di fiuto sospetto che il
rosso che non ti trasformato il principe
azzurro
questo rospo ma io scegliereste rosso 8
un po numero due
preferiresti da mons
a un pozzo cadere da un pozzo o essere
colpito da un cavallo oddio ma
soprattutto i terribili quelle
in entrambi i casi non ti salvi e voi
quale scegliereste se fosse costretti
casi da un pozzo viene colpito da un
cavallo forse seccati da un pozzo è che
proprio per niente perché troppo
profondo però forse ti colpisce il
cavallo ma che forse vuole entrare
qualche sono anche distrugge del tutto
quindi caccia la banchina numero 3
preferiresti avere labbra enormi o avere
occhi e noi ossia entrambi da questa
foto come angeli stata fatta comunque
entrambe molto inquietanti
e tu cosa sei gli occhi enormi a si
possa vedere tutto perché mi dai cechi
vitale tar petta e ma sembra inizio na
li ho portato i miei occhi sono già
piccoli quindi almeno un po di occhi
presterebbero così è svolto da scegliere
se io penso che sceglierei labbra enorme
perché il mio che sono già abbastanza
grandi teli pazzo enormi diventerei un
alieno quindi invece labbra dipende
insomma se sono così fanno un po paura
però voi cosa scegliereste
senza fare nei conventi numero 4
preferiresti non celebrare mai il natale
o non celebrare mai il tuo compleanno a
questo è complicata devo dire tu cosa
sei
io faccio una scelta più incentrata
verso me stesso preferisco non celebrare
il natale invece celebrare il mio
compleanno è nato e si cela drom anche
30 noi non facciamo mai niente al nostro
compleanno da anni che non facciamo mai
in casa altri compleanni però anch'io se
ieri non celebra il natale invece il
compleanno per risparmiare sui regali
perché non sei il natale mi rende un po
triste persone che i genitori che hanno
perso i genitori che non posso i loro
cari o lo so mi dà un po di se stessa il
natale facendo soffrire anche per voi è
così quindi sì direi non celebrare mai
il natale voi cosa scegliete 5
preferiresti aver amato e perso oppure
non aver mai amato
caspita il proprio poetica questa allora
cosa scegli vabbè penso che bell'azione
che si avvicina più alla vita ovvero
modo è perso non amare mai
cioè non aver mai amato aver amato è
perso
se mi perdi pazienza devo fare come mai
mi mangerò qualcosa di dolce è perché se
non hai mai amato non soffri però non
sai cosa si prova usato allora sì
decisamente la scelta più stanze
aggravate e bene
perché non aver amato non sai neanche
che cosa dice basta
cosa ti sei perso e voi cosa scegliete
però considerando che avverà moto è aver
perso o dire che soffrì tantissimo è dei
programmi tv come speriamo che non si
tratti di buttarli anche quasi dal
palazzo
preferiresti ricevere come regalo questi
cagnolini o ricevere come regalo questi
cattivi
noi siamo dei grandissimi fan di tutti
tutti tutti tutti li amiamo e canicattì
cose su tutte e due
siamo un po più gattari ci piacciono di
più regali quindi tempo dei grandissimi
fa contatti quindi entrambi gambe almeno
gatto e voi scegliete gattini e
cagnolini fa7 preferiresti preferire
rimanere a rainato in mare ho perso nel
deserto dei ha fatto è terribile
sarebbero due incubi per me to business
il rito rame ha paura e non il mare cioè
in generale le grandi distese d'acqua
mi fa paura infatti nave in barca e un
po fa un po paura anche quando guardi
giovedì la qualità nera nonostante io
sia sarda quindi io penso che preferirei
ax essere personal deserto hai veramente
poche possibilità che quello che non
venga salvarti ma almeno non resti di
annegare entro qualche cammello che
passeggia di sbarchi
trascinare ovviamente il mare molto
rischioso macchina del deserto c'è solo
il sole il caldo meno caldo come i
serpenti pure da considerare nel deserto
e nel mare però insistono tutto ciò che
ti mangiano le vitali preferire il mare
sperando titolando del 20 a prendere
oggi ovvero rischi di annegare in mare
brutto è un deserto rischi di seccare
veri morire seccate fiamme gatta non so
secondo me morì annegato un ep protetto
2 pisana però io in questo caso a
scegliere il mare rosa ok deserto è la
dedizione vediamo due cose che si piace
un sacco qua preferiresti vivere nel
mondo di harry potter o vivere nel mondo
dei pokémon tutte in pokémon dentro lì
poster per ideale cosa bacchette più
piccato che ancora sarebbe fantastico su
questi assegni
io pokémon più ufficiosa più carino e
divertente non ci devi ammazzare dalle
bacchette è però devi farli combattere
tra di loro di loro anche se il viaggio
harry potter
preferisco e poco conto se si celi
governi potere che anche se sono una fan
di entrambi sono più una grande fan di
harry potter e poi penso che siamo molto
più divertente diventare una strega con
la bacchetta
così si scatenano mai e poi posso anche
volare con lo scopo ma l'albero e tu lo
sai tu hi fi che spieghiamo con la
bacchetta il tuo marito poco il turbo
sabbia come per cento voi cosa
scegliereste facessero sapere nei
commenti
e anzi che ti realizzano quindi il segno
della lampada realizza un tuo desiderio
oggi basta e basta oppure tre desideri
in un anno però da quando partono perché
almeno su treviso spoiler ma non ce
l'hai
subito si è però nel frattempo sceglie
un desiderio poi man mano vedi come
vanno le cose
quindi puoi fare aspetti quattro mesi
dicono 3x4 12 quindi ogni quattro mesi
c'è un desiderio
quindi non è male quindi puoi cambiare
il corso delle cose se gli oggi potresti
già dire tu apri una certa più saggia
tre desideri in una tela e subito devi
aspettare ma almeno stanotte non voglio
pensarci bene uno oggi a si disputerà
testate se sbaglio questo mezzo di
quell'altra sigarette che desiderio
chiedereste del genio della lampada
essere troppo in anticipo essere un
pubblico colto il ritardo è impresa
difficile perché non è troppo in ritardo
e l'isi notro portata non voglio esserlo
ma un pochino in ritardo e poi a volte
essere su quell'anticipo brutto perché
devi aspettare liti a noi non sai cosa
fare
magari se freddo o caldo e difficile
beh io scelgo quello che mi rispecchia
essere tra benanti capitale euro non per
buttare servizi che l'appuntamento
a mezzogiorno lui arriva alle 11 e
aspettare per un'ora con largo anticipo
lui dalla sera prima si deve preparare
tutto e non sai mai mancate c'è un
imprevisto all'improvviso e quindi se
sei già pronto lo ha già calcolato
abbastanza puntuale però voglio arrivare
tantissimo però dipende perché si arrivi
in ritardo ad esempio se devi prendere
un aereo e arrivi un pochettino in
ritardo sono fatte a dio po in anticipo
discorsi un sacco però almeno non ti
viene l'ansia ragione voi cosa scegliete
se sapessi mangeresti un armadio o una
rana donne sono delle due perché vabbè
partita non vegetariani
anche se non lo fossimo non ce la faremo
mai a mangiarli la troverete
posso fare nessuna delle due veramente
verrebbe proprio la notra fatto
l'abbiamo preparata sarebbe una loro
nozze o mamma secondo te cosa
non lo so cosa fa meno senso mamma mia
immagine la lumaca super single mode la
rana non sa neanche come si cena tiranno
le le zampe le coscienze le corse si
danno e basta e le cose buttano via
non lo so
forse serviva la lumaca si poté io mi
fanno schifo e penna tutte e due ma
serve la rubata poi cosa scegliete
scrivete nei commenti essere il re o
regina o salvare mille gattini e
cagnolini da molto forte salvare
l'animale allora scritto quella volta
che sfruttano i commenti perché su quel
che quali risposte saranno tutte come
quella buttare gattino lei con
temperature e scelte secondo me essere
re o regina ed i ratti quanti di salvare
gli animali tutti non mille a tutti
tutti tutti ero in effetti poi perché
nessuno teneva il manager e forse poi
così riesce a salvarne di più però non
lo so ho paura che potrebbero funzionare
se quindi io sono comunque salvare
quelle cattivi cagnolini pubblico
[Musica]
karanka
basta vedere un'immagine come facci
basta vedere un'immagine di gatti e cani
che si sciogliamo non si sapesse che
furgoni e così e comunque noi sediamo
salvare i gattini e cagnolini voi cosa
serie the è perché magari si ha una
motivazione interessando l'a14
preferirsi mangiare la carta o mangiare
la plastica ma perché comunque dico già
io sceglierei mangiare la carta perché
è più semplice cellulosa è piuttosto che
la bligh
forse la carta si riesce a digerire la
plastica 9 15 questo mi sa che l'ultimo
quindi attenzione preferiti essere
inseguito da un clown malefico da come
si vede dall'immagine o non usare mai
tutte tempora non usare mai più di tutte
le fonti queste promesse difficile
perché essere inseguiti dalla polizia
che remo tutti addosso rimargina che lo
doveva fare la spesa sia in questo
dietro lo sarà mai più il tuo telefono
oppure uno che ti insegue così quindi
non trovi sempre dietro a me l'immagino
tra gli scaffali possiamo radicato e tu
stai cercando qualcosa prendi cereali si
siede anche lui no va bene questa scelta
uno scialbo clown si divertirebbe troppo
ma immagino che lei dorme
proprio il coltello con potabile è
diventato ci sarebbe pure vedere la
reazione degli altri no questo che mi
segue sempre dietro a mettere questo
quello in aereo come fai ebbe solo fatta
solo il biglietto di roma si vede sotto
la media e si imbarcano stata las vegas
[Risate]
allora veramente difficile questa quindi
to the clouds
io non penso che riuscirei a vivere con
un clown che sta a casa col consenso
tutta la vita però non usare mai più il
mio telefono
diciamo che se non avessi il canale
youtube perché devo sempre controllare
dei video sono stati pubblicati i
commenti e tutto sfondo dovessi
rispondere però potrei provare a farlo
dal computer
anzi sai che ho visto dei video che
facciamo degli esperimenti dire non ho
senza telefono quest'anno provare a fare
senza telefono per 24 ore fa sapere se
vi interessa questo challenge vediamo
poi come stiano farebbe davvero
impattiamo carichiamo qui al telefono e
che si vabbè basta non lo facciamo più
oppure realizziamo questa scelta nella
vita reale cioè se tu hai scelto il club
mi travesto da clown a frassineti
dopotutto incarna e tu puoi usare il
telefono invece non posso usare il
telefono
tu che è certo invece
il telefono io che faccio mi devo
vestire da telefono allora qual cosa se
siete tra questi
fateci sapere nei commenti fatti sapere
anche perché quindi lasciate sono finite
per oggi fateci sapere se vede un altro
bisogno di questa noi si divertono
sempre uno stato
lasciate un bel like su questo video
emilia siamo qua ora 4 caselline se
volete vedere l'altro episodio
precedente video divertenti challenge
nuovi video cliccate su quella che
preferite
buona visione